let's talk about your new single boys
that's the difference
it really explores the difference
between a boy and a man
um so how would you describe being a man
i look at a man who's being i get
somebody that's mature
and makes the right decisions and has
character
and unfortunately it takes a while to
become one i think
truly because as a boy you make all the
wrong decisions you make all the wrong
choices and
you do a lot of stupid things so really
this album is kind of about
my wanting to reach that goal and the
experience
life's been for me being a boy so do you
feel like you've reached that goal of
being a man
no no i absolutely don't
[Music]
love you let's talk about your amazing
collaboration uh with mickey guyton i
mean how did that all come about she's
awesome
mickey is amazing i've kind of fallen in
love with mickey and who she is and
just her character her song that she has
you know really powerful song what are
you gonna tell
her but what are you gonna tell her
when she's wrong it put a lump in my
throat and i'm like you know i think
mickey would emote
this song perfectly and uh we approached
her and her camp her team and they said
yes
so what's one thing that you wish you
could tell yourself your younger self
that you
now know one of the biggest things would
be surround yourself with good people
like
yeah don't waste time on people that you
know you want to be with but
just because you want to be liked you
know i think you need to i think you
need to learn how to love yourself and i
think i go back and
tell my younger self you're okay you're
not you know you're not
awesome but you're you're not the worst
either
i love that